standing on the denipro river in
russian-occupied Ukraine it's Europe's
largest nuclear power station and it's
on the front line of a war that is
getting worse
and according to two workers who spoke
to us on condition of anonymity and at
Great personal risk it is a nuclear
catastrophe waiting to happen
if we are talking about the worst
scenario at a minimum it impacts half of
Europe half of Russia and a huge part of
the Mediterranean the level of
radioactive pollution and most
importantly the area of contamination
will be thousands of square kilometers
of land and sea it would be much much
worse than Fukushima and worse than
Chernobyl these grainy images show
Russian forces storming the plants last
year
since then satellite imagery shows the
damage caused by shelling with each side
blaming the other
the workers told us Russia's
deliberately targeted power lines to cut
the supply of electricity to Ukraine
these lines are essential for plant
safety basic maintenance is also not
getting done there is the same deficit
of workers for repairs who can actually
do the servicing and fix problems the
quality of the workers is lower because
the qualified staff left so generally
the situation here is deteriorating
there are also fears Moscow May escalate
the conflict by staging a false flag
attack Ukraine accuses the Kremlin of
nuclear terrorism regarding the
consequences as with Chernobyl it all
depends on what the Russians do if they
are going to do it deliberately if they
have such a goal for example to blow
something up that could result in
disaster they can do it
we don't know their goals
the power station has been under
occupation for the last 15 months
now workers are telling us that in the
last few weeks military activity inside
has dramatically increased they've
witnessed Russian soldiers moving in
more armor guns and ammunition as they
fortify their positions
in August last year Russian military
hardware was filmed moving into the
plants there's now more evidence the
power station is being used as a base
ahead of Ukraine's counter-offensive
Ukrainian Armed Forces will not shell
the station that's why they are
multiplying the numbers of troops and
vehicles here the thing is one month and
a half ago there were two times fewer
troops on the power station and now
there are two times more which means
they are definitely preparing for the
counter-offensive
Russia denies its compromising safety
but the UK Ministry of Defense says
these are sandbagged fighting positions
on the rooftops of nuclear reactors
it is hard to know what is exactly going
on inside
we understand technicians are routinely
intimidated to keep their silence
everyone has their own story and I think
the most important thing is not to get
into their hands because it's unlikely
you will get out and still be the human
you were when you went in
the international atomic energy agency
continues to express grave concerns
about the nuclear plants and is calling
for the area to be demilitarized
immediately
there is no sign that will happen in
fact quite the opposite
Alex Rossi Sky News zapparesia region